あのねぇ
本当に寒いんすよ
がちでおれは
怒ってるからね
ほんとに寒いがちで寒い
無理っす寒すぎて
俺は今日ね、学校さぼろうと思ったよ
さぼったけど
というわけで君たち、カレーライスは好きですか？
僕はね、カレーライスみたいなもんなので（？）
僕はもうカレーライス大好きです
君たちの想像をはるかに超える好きさです
カレー屋さんの有名なお店があるじゃないですか
カレーここいちばん！
ここいちってカレー屋さん！ここいち！あぁ///
で、そのカレー屋さんにですね、甘さを選べる
そう、ちょまっておれなんか言葉がおかしい
ここいちってカレー屋さんのすごいところは
カレーを自分でカスタマイズできるんですよ
例えば、辛いカレーが食べたい人は辛さを調節したり
たくさん食べたいって人は量を調節したり
自由にカスタマイズとかできてね
もうほんとね、グレートなカレー屋しゃしょしょしゅ
でもな、ひとつだけ弱点があるんだよ
俺みたいな甘口しか食べれない輩には
弱点がありまして、甘口が調節できないんす
辛口とかはいろんな種類があるんですけども
甘口は甘口しかないっていうね
なんでもないです(なんでもないんかいｗ)
なんだけども、最近
ここいちでなんとですね、甘さを選べるようになったそうです
1甘2甘3甘4甘5甘ってどんどん強くなってくんですよ甘さが
5甘なんてね1甘の20倍なんすよ
100円多いんすよ
高(すぎる)
5甘を今日買ってきました
これが5甘です
もっとも辛いのが今ここに
あぁちがう甘いのだ
こっかれー、ここいちばん屋で一番辛い
一番甘いのが今ここにあります
実験的にやってるらしいです
一部の店舗で甘さを選べるってシステムが導入されてて
たまたまそれがきててなんとか買えたんでね
食べてみようよ！
いやちがう俺が食べます
全国に30店舗くらいしかないらしいです
1甘の20倍の甘さなんで
あんまりいっちゃだめなんですけど
いちおう2甘と3甘は食ったんすよ
2甘と3甘はすごいおいしかったです
まさに俺が求める理想の甘さだったんですけど
5甘を食べる勇気がなくて
店員さんに聞いたんすよ
5甘ってどうすっかっていったら
まずいです！って言われました
あ、これいっちゃだめっすよこれほんとにだめなんで
くびになっちゃうかもしれないんで
じゃあ早速食べてみようと思います！5甘です！
これまじ大丈夫？
じゃあいただきます
ゑ？
ゑ？ゑ？うーーーっそ
あぁーーーやば
やばいなんかね
簡単に言うとあれです
はちみつライスみたいな
ご飯にはちみつをかけて食べてる感じです
5甘はやめてね、2甘3甘くらいがおススメだと思います
ぜひ、食べてみてください
じゃあな！